In this video, we're going to show you how you can configure burp to use SAML based SSL when
you're using as your active directory as your IDP. Now, Microsoft have recently rebranded as
your active directory to Microsoft Entra. In this video, we're going to be using both terms
interchangeably. So before you start, you'll need to make sure that your web server URL within burp
settings includes both the protocol and ports information. If you need help doing this, you
can see our documentation pages on how you can do so. The first thing we're going to do
is add burp to your trusted applications. To do this, you'll need to log into burp as an
administrator and then from the settings menu, click integrations. We're then going to scroll
down to SAML and click configure. Once we're on this page, we're going to go to the Microsoft
Entra website and find the application which we want to integrate with burp. To do this,
you can go to identity, applications, and then enterprise applications, and then find your
application in the list. Under setup single sign-on, we're going to click get started,
and then we're going to choose SAML as the SSL method. At this point, we need to copy some
configuration from burp to put into this configuration page. To do this, we can go to enterprise,
copy the relying party trust identifier, and paste it as the identifier entity ID field.
We're then going to copy the relying party service URL, and paste it as the reply URL. We're then
going to save this configuration, and once it's saved, we're going to close this dialogue, and
then close this dialogue, and click no I'll test later. We're then going to download the
Federation metadata XML file from the SAML certificate section. This file contains some information,
which we can use in burp to fill out the fields for the SAML configuration. Once you've downloaded
it, we're going to go back to burp, and then type in the company name to show in the logging field
within burp. So I'm just going to type portspool here, and then under SAML configuration,
I'm going to click import metadata, and then choose the file I just downloaded. If you want to use
single sign out, you'll need to put in the service provider certificate, and the service provider
private key. We're not going to use it in the demo, so I'm just going to toggle this off, and then
click save. At this point, we need to configure how Azure should send the groups over to burp. To do
this, we're going to go back to Microsoft Enter, scroll to attributes and claims, and click edit,
and then click add a group claim. You'll need to choose which groups should be returned in the claim.
I'm just going to choose all groups here. Now if your active directory is on premise, you're going
to need to change this source attribute field to the SAML account name. If your users are managed
directly in Azure Active Directory, this will need to be group ID. My users are managed in Azure Active
Directory, so I'm going to click group ID. For advanced options, we're going to enable that,
and then click customize the name of the group claim. The name is going to be group with a capital G,
and the namespace is going to be http colon slash slash schemas dot xml soap dot org for slash claims.
I'm then going to save this configuration, and then I'm going to go back to burp and sign out.
At this point, you can see the option to sign in with the company name that we provided before,
and then I'm going to click login. I'll be redirected through the Microsoft SSO flow,
and then you can see straight away that I've been signed in. And that is how you integrate burp
with Azure Active Directory for SAML based SSO.